what did this whole mindset these nine
tenants like what what what's the
inspiration behind all of this yeah um I
think I alluded to this earlier my real
why in the world is my kids couldn't
breathe they were allergic to everything
dust dogs food you name it
um they would go into this anaphylactic
shock they couldn't breathe um they were
taking ambulance trips to the hospital
we had to use epipens doctors kept
giving the same [ __ ] to lose both of
them both of them and where were you
living when this was happening same
place you are right now no not not same
place in the city we're living in the
city okay um yeah right in the middle of
the city and um it was more EpiPen more
Benadryl more allergy shots same thing
kept happening and what we realized is
you know we have the extreme issues
where they would have to go to the
hospital but if you really paid
attention they hardly ever could just
take a deep breath they were always
having issues breathing they always had
these bags around their eyes you don't
really notice it because this is your
everyday right and um you know one day
I'm like you know what enough is enough
I'm not giving that to them anymore you
couldn't go anywhere I mean they were
allergic to our own dog dog they might
go to a friend's house and you've got to
have like your whole rescue kit
emergency plan exit strategy you got to
tell everybody around here's what here's
what you got to do I'm like man you
can't raise your kids like that like
this is your job as a dad to figure this
out and so with enough research I Came
Upon This like ancestral living
principle that these forces that enabled
us to be healthy these robust strong
healthy individuals since the beginning
of time maybe we still need these things
right which our sleep eat moves you'll
connect cold Sun fight and bond but
primarily I said you know what let's
start with eat what if what we're
feeding them what if what I'm feeding
them is creating these issues and so we
just got rid of all the processed foods
it was like overnight liver Queen did it
she threw away I couldn't believe it
either because I like to eat a lot of
ice cream you know I mean at the time I
was like I would do a whole container
you know and I and I couldn't believe it
I'm like well hold on you know time out
time out I'm never gonna do that again
and so she got rid of absolutely
everything and so through that
transition you know like she would put
chiefly liver and bone marrow and egg
yolks in front of them you think they
want to eat that of course not
especially raw forget it they wouldn't
touch it they wouldn't touch it she
would make bone soups they wouldn't
touch it after three or four days of not
eating you know they started eating it
they were hungry and then they wanted
more of it and then immediately like we
saw the lights come on and we saw this
personality this vibrancy that we had
never seen before and then it's like how
dulled down were they and we didn't know
this until going through this process
I'm like holy [ __ ] you know maybe this
eat ancestrally works and so um I had
read this in a book and uh Sally
Fallon's nourishing Traditions there's a
couple of other books that that we had
read at that time but that was a
landmark book for us and then we started
to think okay from first principle
thinking what else are we missing you
know like our kids are going from the
house to a car to another building right
and they're not getting outside and when
they're outside we're putting sunblock
on them how much sun are they getting
did we evolve with sun you know there's
so many of these things you know first
principle thing I'm like okay what did
we get right what did we get wrong how
can we expand upon this and um until we
started to go and visit with with these
tribes and the Amazon in Africa in
Mongolia to study their ways to see if
we can validate the nine ancestral
tenants maybe expand upon the nine
ancestral tenants so when we figure this
out for our kids you know I thought okay
like what kind of piece of [ __ ] doesn't
share this with the world yeah so that
that's what I'm like okay this is what
we're gonna do from now on every company
is going to be about teaching the nine
ancestral tenants and so um really it
just took off they killed all the
grass-fed grass finish from the bone
marrow to this I do all of it I get all
Frozen and Chip you get it from him no
no the heart and soil 100 that's what
I'm gonna talk about sponsors oh you get
all this I I 100 we're living in the
like the like you said grass-fed the
bone marrow I haven't I've tried the raw
but it's not I you know just by itself I
put on top of the stick I you know raw
you know raw honey the cheese fruits
vegetables I'm sorry barely an adventure
are you a vegetable
you like vegetables get down could get
Donald but the bread is gone I I and I'm
telling you right now mind bought
everything else is a completely
different attitude now when I eat like
[ __ ] even a little bit I feel it like I
want to pass out if I eat like bread and
glue and I'm I and I'm dead serious
after lunch with that I want to take a
nap so it's 100 I mean like I said the
Toronto O'Malley said the same thing
that people might be like oh well how
could you believe now that [ __ ] works it
really really works getting the Sun and
getting the right food in you night and
day you know there's just
maybe hundreds of thousands of anecdotes
about this I mean if if you just go on
Amazon and look at some reviews about
people that have turned to this
lifestyle you know again I just want to
like remind everybody that most people
go to a job they hate they come home to
a life that that they don't love they
sedate themselves and distract
themselves to call it a day to call it a
week call you know it's like
um there's a better life to live and
most of these things are free to do
eight of them are free to do accessible
to everybody and and even the food
aspect of this I think it's a wash you
know or you can possibly save money on
food nobody says you got to get a stick
you can go get you know ground beef yeah
when I started this the organs cost like
two dollars but most butchers were given
the organs 100 100 yeah we're giving the
organs away um and so I mean now now the
organs actually they're expensive
but but that's how the whole thing
started and you know there's there's a
lot of vegans and vegetarians that come
they're like hey I think a lot of what
you're saying is cool but this whole
other thing I got a problem with I'm
like cool you know what there's eight
other ancestral tenants for you right
focus on those other rate and if those
other eight don't get you leading a
better Kick-Ass life then you can talk
about just introducing liver you know if
that doesn't get you better just think
about that and one other thing I want to
point out you know my takeaway when
um by the way Joe Rogan you know and
Derek talked about me for like 30
minutes and someone said how'd you feel
about them like man I couldn't believe
they talked about me for 30 minutes and
and at the end what Joe Rogan said is
that liver is great that he eats it all
the time and then Derek said Heats it
every day yep you know liver is king is
not about my name is liver Kings this is
not about calling myself a king this is
about if I can say liver King three
times in a one minute clip on Instagram
what you're always going to hear is the
name is liver King because liver is King
these guys are saying liver is King you
know my takeaway from that 30-minute
assessment was like thank God they
promoted liver you know thank God that
they did that because that's such a low
love lover for so many people to do when
you start eating liver most people feel
more energy more drive more
determination their mood's getting
better and then then I'm hoping that
they're thinking okay what else is this
guy talking about now if you get early
morning sun now most people don't know
that early morning sun sets your whole
circadian rhythm you know and then
connecting I mean there's so many of
these things that are free easy
accessible to do and will make such a
massive difference specifically liver
though that's what you're saying we're
all liver not meat not protein
specifically liver let me share a little
bit about that with you when you go and
you visit with the Hudson or any of
these permanent culture tribes they
don't even eat the muscle meat they go
for the liver first they go for the
organs and and first I read this in in
one of these books and uh I forget which
book it was actually but I read it in a
book and I'm like really do they do that
and then when you actually see them
throw the muscle meat to the dogs and
give it to the birds it's like holy [ __ ]
this is actually true yeah they eat the
organs and they start with the liver and
bone marrow usually you know animals in
the wild do the same thing you know it's
enough to watch that on on a documentary
I'm like okay that's cool right I can
say that as much as I want but I gotta
go see this now what about chop liver
what about it in Judaism all the Jews
they got the chop liver you know what am
I chop level that whole thing is chopped
liver in that in in your diet any kind
of liver straight up yeah and shout out
to all the Jews out there you chopped
liver you just made his day I just made
my day my mom would always
apparently that's a compliment good good
well it does but it does lose its uh it
does lose its like it's pure obviously
when you cook it because eating it raw I
am not going to front I put a little uh
light soy sauce with some sesame oil I
put some green onion I just I don't
really I chop it up I dice I swallow
every day I put a little maple syrup on
my little maple syrup really salty you
ate liver every day every single day I I
bought it online I chop it up because
it's frozen it I thought I put in those
little freezers Ziploc bags and if you
go in my freezer I have right now I have
a hundred little Frozen pieces I defrost
it Ryan I defrost it chop it up I told
my dick Patrick I'm telling you right
now it's the energy wow and so I swear
and people in the office like yo it's
Vinnie on cocaine I'm like no I'm on
liver we got the liver kids
here right now so with all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red are
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan bought
one then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future looks
spread toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]